give directly is the non-profit that
lets you send cash directly to the
world's poorest household which is more
cost effective than so many other types
of giving it's how you know you're
maximizing your donations help us reach
our goal of fifteen thousand dollars by
the end of the year go to give
directly.org Pacman
well we start today with a shift in the
balance of power potentially in the
Senate days after Herschel Walker
thankfully was defeated by the incumbent
Democratic senator from Georgia Raphael
Warnock and we said what great news it
won't be 50 50 in the Senate but it will
be 51.49 in favor of Democrats
Democratic but shaky Democrat let's call
her what she is shaky Democrat Kirsten
Cinema announces she is leaving the
Democratic party and becoming an
independent now I know I know I know
let's resist the urge to call this what
it may be at face value A desperate
attempt for attention from someone who
by virtue of the Democrats getting 51
rather than 50 seats
immediately has a diminished amount of
power in the senate in the sense that
she alone cannot prevent Democrats from
getting a simple majority let's actually
sort of talk it through and see what she
had to say NPR reporting here's what
Cinema's switch from Democrat to
Independent could mean for the Senate
and the article uh explains Cinema's
move is unlikely to change the Power
Balance in the Senate uh as it comes
days after Senator Raphael Warnock won
the Georgia runoff election to give
Democrats a 51-49 majority that includes
two Independents who caucus with
Democrats those are of course Senators
Bernie Sanders of Vermont and Angus King
of Maine Cinema said she doesn't want to
fit in a box and the article goes on to
talk about the direction that the Senate
could go in and also talks about
Arizona's 2024 Outlook as Kirsten Cinema
is up in 2024 and the fact that she is
no longer a Democrat could of course
mean that now Democrats could hold a
primary and have a candidate who runs
against Cinema you could end up with a
Democrat a Republican and independent
Kirsten Cinema in Arizona that would
change the Dynamics of that race but
we're going to table that for the time
being here's my my primary thought about
this and we're going to hear from Bernie
Sanders in a moment about this my
primary thought
is that this does seem motivated by a
desire for attention
particularly with the win by Raphael
Warnock it seems as though the question
now is well is it 5149 or is it 50 50
and the question really has to do with
caucusing Angus King and Bernie Sanders
are not Democrats but they caucus with
Democrats and that's where we got for
the last two years it's 50 50 rather
than 48 50 and 2. let's listen to what
Kirsten Cinema had to say she was
interviewed by Jake Tapper about this
powerful decision that she made you're
here to make a significant announcement
I've registered as an Arizona
independent I know some people might be
a little bit surprised by this but
actually I think it makes a lot of sense
we're not that surprised Kirsten you
know a growing member of arizonans and
people like me just don't feel like we
fit neatly into one party's box or the
other and so like many across the state
and the nation I've decided to leave
that partisan process and really just
focus on the work that I think matters
to Arizona into our country which is
solving problems and getting things done
now understand that
being in the being in the Senate and
being a Democrat and then saying I'm
leaving the Democratic party because I
no longer fit into that box now I'm
outside of partisanship this is one of
the silliest things I mean we've talked
about this before it's sort of like
people who say
I don't vote because I I think all of
these excuse me Republican politicians
and Democratic politicians none of them
have our best interests in mind so I'm
above and outside of the partisan Fray
by never voting for any of these losers
that's a very political decision it's
still political and I would argue it is
still partisan because you are basically
saying I don't see an appreciable
difference between Democrats and
Republicans even though there are so
many differences that I'm saying they're
equally bad and I'm voting for that's a
very partisan and political statement so
this is starting to get into the kind of
enlightened centrism that we've been
critical of let's listen to the rest of
her statement here so
your voting record is pretty capital D
Democratic I mean your views are
generally that of a moderate Centrist
Democrat how does leaving the party
change how you do your job well I don't
think anything will change about how I
do my job
arizonans sent me to the United States
Senate to be an independent voice for
our state and I'll continue doing that
That's a classic by the way oh I was
sent here to be an independent voice to
think for myself all right but now it is
interesting I will mention that there is
footage of Kirsten Cinema chastising Joe
Lieberman for doing the exact same thing
going from the Democratic party to
Independence she now she's doing it and
now it's great now it's a sign of virtue
but in the past she was critical of Joe
Lieberman for doing exactly that I've
been negotiated with the Senate so what
does that mean well in the Senate we no
longer have 60 votes some would argue
that we never had 60 because one of
those was Joseph liberated right but
that's oh whatever
um
um so so now there's um I think as a
president so eloquently said on
Wednesday there's none of this pressure
this false pressure to get to 60. so
what that means is that um the Democrats
um can stop
um kowtowing to Joe Lieberman and
instead seek other avenues
isn't that interesting the way that
they've had to cow Tao or will have to
cow Tao to Kirsten Cinema and Joe
manchin so the hypocrisy
adds to my feeling that this is a plea
for attention and she's getting the
attention and here I am covering it as
well because it is relevant we will have
to see if and how this changes Cinema's
voting let's now talk about the reaction
from Bernie Sanders I don't want to
spend a ton of time on Bernie's reaction
to Kirsten Cinema leaving the Democratic
party but I do think it's important and
interesting because Bernie also is an
independent who is made very very clear
I caucus with the Democrats and there
are specific reasons why Bernie is an
independent Vermont is also a unique
state in terms of its political
orientation and Alignment Vermont
Republicans are different than National
Republicans and gun ownership is a
different thing in Vermont we've talked
about sort of the interesting different
dynamics of Vermont Bernie Sanders
appeared on CNN to talk about I mean he
I don't know that he appeared to talk
about Kirsten Cinema but Dana Bash
certainly talked to him about it and he
was pretty clear he's not super
impressed with Kirsten Cinema calls her
a corporate Democrat and says quite a
few accurate but critical things about
her let's take a listen to what Bernie
had to say you are an independent she is
now the third official independent of
the U.S Senate uh joining you in Angus
King of Maine what do you think of her
decision and also what you just heard in
her interview with Jake
I don't want to spend a whole lot of
time on Senator Cinema she has her
reasons uh Donna I happen to suspect
that it's probably a lot to do with
politics back in Arizona I think are the
Democrats there are not all that
enthusiastic about somebody who helped
sabotage some of the most important
legislation that protects the interests
of working families and so that's that's
a pretty clear shot across the bow
voting rights and and so forth so I
think it really has to do with her uh
political aspirations uh for the future
in Arizona but for us I think nothing
much has changed in terms of the
functioning of the U.S Senate the good
news is that we now have uh 51 votes
we'll have a majority on committees it
means that we can go forward and start
protecting the interests of working
families and deal with the reality that
we are increasingly living in an
oligarchy where the billionaire class
and large corporations uh control almost
every aspect of our country so I would
hope very much that with this Newman
charity Democrats will down and start
fighting for the needs of ordinary
Americans so I want to talk about some
of those issues in a second but first
you were a very important figure on the
campaign Trail for progressives ahead of
the midterms as you normally are I'm
sure you're going to be campaigning for
candidates in 2024. the outgoing Arizona
Democratic Party official uh one of them
says that he expects Democrats will run
their own candidate against her is that
a good idea would you support a
democratic opponent against Senator
Cinema good question
I support Progressive candidates all
over this country people who have the
guts to take on powerful special
interests I don't know what's going to
be happening in Arizona we'll see who
they nominate but certainly it's
something I will take a hard look at
does she have the guts to take on on
powerful special interests
no no she is a corporate Democrat uh who
has in fact along with Senator manchin
sabotaged enormously important
legislation so two sides to this of
course number one to the extent that
Kirsten Cinema will caucus with
Democrats and mostly continue voting
with Democrats even if she is a Centrist
corporate Democrat as Bernie says her
vote is still useful and if 60 votes are
needed at least plausibly that's one
fewer Republican vote that would be
necessary fine but at the same time
Bernie is clear about Kirsten Cinema's
political views and as we've seen over
the last two years there's been a lot of
playing koi with her supposed
Independence which is really Center
right-ism at the end of the day Bernie's
being very clear while being sort of
diplomatic we really can't say much more
about how the next two years are going
to go without seeing how they go it's
just guesswork and predicting as the
bills start being voted on we're very
quickly going to learn much more about
it but good to see that Bernie isn't
confused about what's going on here many
of you wrote To Me
and you said David sir I'm a big strong
guy but I have tears in my eyes as those
stories often go because as I looked
through this gay marriage bill that just
passed
it's not really clear that it actually
guarantees gay marriage
and those people are absolutely correct
absolutely correct and so I want to talk
about that the reporting widespread from
over the weekend and late last week Bill
to protect same-sex marriage rights
clears Congress the idea here was let's
codify gay marriage before maybe
Republicans come for it and the Supreme
Court makes a decision on gay marriage
like they did with Roe v Wade we have
seen many on the right say
the gay marriage decision was just as
wrongly decided by a prior Supreme Court
as was Roe v Wade making it clear they
are setting their sights and targeting
gay marriage as well as a whole but
access to contraception and other things
as well
so the idea was let's codify it let's
guarantee gay marriage and indeed the
house on Thursday is the New York Times
rights gave final approval to
legislation to mandate Federal
recognition for same-sex marriages hmm
that's interesting what does that mean
the vote was 258 to 169 with one member
voting present this now goes to Joe
Biden who will of course sign in I don't
want to sort of like sugar coat this or
dance around it the legislation doesn't
require states to issue marriage
licenses for same-sex couples that is
not what the legislation does
States currently have to do that because
of the 2015 decision from the Supreme
Court
if that decision were overturned even
despite this legislation
States would no longer have to issue
same-sex marriages what the law says is
that states that uh that all states
must recognize same-sex marriages that
were entered into someplace else so let
me give you the exact scenario imagine
now that gay marriage has been codified
even though it hasn't really now that
this law has passed imagine that in a
year or in two years or whenever there
is a case that gets to the Supreme Court
much like the case that ultimately
overturned Roe v Wade gets to the
Supreme Court and the Supreme Court does
decide hey it was wrongly decided it was
wrongly decided so we're doing away with
the 2015 decision that uh made gay man
that banned bans on same-sex marriage
does this new law mean that if Kentucky
doesn't want to anymore they have to
enter issue same-sex marriage licenses
no it doesn't all this law says is that
if the 2015 gay marriage decision is
overturned Kentucky would have to
recognize same-sex marriages from
wherever so you wouldn't be able to deny
a gay couple married elsewhere all of
the same rights that married people have
in Kentucky but it does not mean that
Kentucky would have to issue same-sex
marriage licenses if the 2015 decision
is overturned so it's better than
nothing but at the same time
if people don't have money to travel in
order to get married somewhere else it's
going to create problems it's going to
create problems for people it doesn't
guarantee gay marriage to anyone it
guarantees if you find a place to get
married
it will have to be a recognized marriage
in all 50 states and again this is all
preemptive it's if the 2015 decision
were to be overturned that is what it
does
and that is what it does not do is it
better than nothing of course it is is
it not really that great if the issue is
let's make sure that no matter what
happens gay and lesbian couples will
continue be being able to get married in
any state yeah it doesn't do that it
absolutely doesn't do that it is what it
is important to understand it now we
know what it is and we press forward
we'll take a quick break and be right
back
I have done a ton of reading about how
to optimize charitable donations we all
have some limited amount we can give and
for me it's important to make sure I'm
giving in the most efficient way when
organizations give cash to families in
need about 90 cents on the dollar
actually goes to the recipient instead
of only about 50 cents of relative
impact with some of the more complex
programs like certain kinds of job
training for example that's why I
reached out to an amazing non-profit
called give directly about partnering
with us because give directly lets you
send cash directly to the world's
poorest households the David Pacman show
is trying to hit fifteen thousand
dollars in donations to give directly
before the year is up that's equal to
about a Year's worth of expenses and
Investments for 15 families in many
cases use the link below giving families
cash lets them choose for themselves
elves how to improve their lives they
buy food they repair their homes they
start a business they buy medication
they pay for their kids schools give
directly is doing truly incredible work
all around the world when you give to
them you're maximizing every hard-earned
dollar that you donate and they need
your help go to give
directly.org Pacman help us get to
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year the link is down below remember
that the David packman show is an
independent media program it's not like
the sort of stuff you get when you turn
on your TV and watch cable for example
we actually depend on the support of our
audience to do what we do the best way
the most direct way the way where we
keep the most pennies out of every
dollar is when you sign up at
joinpakman.com we do an extra show every
day for our members we provide a
commercial free audio and video stream
for our members and we also do members
only Town Hall events the next of which
is coming uh very very soon sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code 24 starts now to get yourself a
tidy little discount listen uh I want to
keep talking about the Twitter files I
know that many of you are following the
Twitter files and I also want to make
very clear what it is it's right wing
bait that's what it is it's meant to get
people who don't really know what's
going on or who don't actually read the
Twitter file threads or who simply are
looking some for something to be
outraged about
to be outraged and to say we all the
stuff we said was happening was
happening and people need to go to jail
or something bad needs to happen so
let's take a step back we have now seen
at least three releases of the Twitter
files the Twitter files are supposedly
exclusive stories given to mat taibi and
Bari Weiss to tweet about
exposing
everything that happened at Twitter
and it turns out that really not that
much happened for example we learned
that there was an effort being made in
2020 by the Biden campaign to have
explicit images of Hunter Biden uh
removed from the platform now they were
new to explicit images of Hunter
published without his consent that's not
allowed on Twitter
per their own terms of service and it's
also against the law in Most states to
publish such images and it was framed by
some on the right as the Biden
Administration is censoring content on
Twitter well there was no Biden
administration at the time so cross that
piece off and they're not really
censoring anything they're asking that
content in violation of Twitter's own
policies be removed it wasn't really a
bombshell
[Music]
um
as the Twitter files have continued
coming out more and more clear thinking
individuals have realized what many of
us realize pretty quickly uh Charlie
wurtzel writes about this in the
Atlantic in an article I encourage you
to read called Elon musk's Twitter files
are bait he doesn't actually want
transparency on the social media
platform and this is of course
absolutely correct the Twitter files
expose no crimes that that are clearly
related to the actions Twitter took I'm
going to get to perjury in a second and
I have no interest in hiding anything
from you the emails I get David you're
hiding this and that
I'm just a guy in a room with a
microphone I'm not hiding anything we'll
get to perjury but the Twitter files
expose no crimes with regard to
Twitter's actions and they don't even
expose violations of Twitter's own terms
of service Twitter's own terms of
service if you want to read them include
a process for a communicating content
that content is violating Twitter's uh
terms of service it includes these very
general catch-alls that these social
media platforms can at the end of the
day decide to moderate content however
the hell they want as long as they're
not doing something like saying we don't
allow Christians to post that would be
against the law
but beyond that all of these platforms
can do this and it's in their terms of
service now you can say you disagree
with it okay but it's in their terms of
service so the point here is the Twitter
files expose no crimes and no violations
of Twitter's own terms of service they
are intended to play
to the right wing persecution complex
we're being censored we're being
silenced we're not allowed to give the
alternative perspectives on covid or on
drinking urine neuron whatever it is
that they want to do when private
businesses tell you here's what we're
doing in our terms of service and you
accept and then they do it there isn't
very much to talk about at worst what
we're learning is something we knew
which is Twitter does what Fox News does
right if you want to accept the most
heavy argument that could be made which
I don't believe is actually defensible
based on video but it would be Twitter
is crafting a partisan measure a message
in through their moderation and
decisions well that's what Fox News does
the difference being Twitter is a
platform on which everybody gets to post
at least in principle Fox News is
broadcasting out one way no connection
between the Biden campaign and the
suspension of Donald Trump on Twitter
which was a big thing that they had
their their hopes very high for the most
interesting part out of all of this to
me
is the part of the files that say the
Trump Administration not campaign
apparently had the exact type of access
to Twitter moderation meaning they had
email addresses they could email so part
of the controversy is that the Biden
campaign rather than
reporting tweets the way you and I have
to had email addresses of people at
Twitter that they could email and say
hey take a look at this take a look at
that you could argue that that's wrong
you could argue the Biden campaign
should have had to use the same system
we all have to use to report tweets fine
but the Twitter files also say that the
Trump
administration had the very same email
access
conservatives are silent about that part
okay
let's now talk about maybe maybe the one
part that maybe is something and you
know I'm getting emails from people
saying David you won't talk about this
listen up folks Buckle in because I'm
talking about it the one thing I can
maybe find that that would be under the
route the the umbrella of what we would
call Criminal
is that there are now allegations that
Jack Dorsey perjured himself former CEO
of Twitter one of the instrumental early
people Jack Dorsey said to Congress
under oath Twitter isn't Shadow Banning
people
according to the Twitter files Twitter
was Shadow Banning people and that thus
that is perjury because Jack lied under
oath let's take a look at the clip from
that hearing years ago I want to read a
few quotes about Twitter's practices and
I just want you to tell me if they're
true or not please uh social media is
being rigged to censor conservatives is
that true of Twitter no
I don't know what Twitter is up to it
sure looks like to me that they're
censoring people and they ought to stop
it are you censoring people no
Twitter Shadow Banning prominent
Republicans
bad is that true no okay so Jack Dorsey
said we are not Shadow Banning people
and it appears based on some of the
stuff that's been released that that
Twitter was so listen very carefully
here
if Jack Dorsey perjured himself
and you can prove it throw the book at
him prosecute him do it I don't care if
you can prove that the shadow band
screenshots released in the Twitter
files are real
and that Jack Dorsey knew that there was
Shadow Banning going on when he
testified right because that's part of
it perjury did you know that you were
telling a lie if you can prove those two
points then go ahead and prosecute him
I do want to remind you however
Republicans spent three years during the
Mueller probe saying lying to Congress
and lying to the FBI that's all you can
get what about the underlying crimes
what about the collusion with Russia
what about this that or the other thing
Financial crimes all you've got is lying
under oath that's the only thing that's
politically targeted those Pro when all
you have is lying those are politically
targeted prosecutions of trump people we
shouldn't even be worried about that
well
if you were saying that during the
Mueller probe then maybe you should be
saying the same thing here
notice I'm not saying that I'm saying if
he perjured himself go after him it
doesn't relate to the type of
criminality that they've been alleging
Twitter engaged in this is just a guy
who maybe lied go after him for it but
by all means but remember that you all
were the ones saying during the Mueller
probe when all you've got is lying you
know you've really got nothing all right
one more Elon Musk story and that the
Elon Musk stuff is just getting worse
and worse and worse Elon Musk tweeted
um over the weekend
oh God he tweeted quote my pronouns are
prosecute slash fouchy
this is basically two different things
one
it's ridiculing and making fun of gender
pronouns which is very very big right
now on the right one of the uh areas
that most excites and titillates the
right at this point in time is being
anti-trans anti-trans is just really big
on the right at this point in time so
Elon Musk is sort of stoking that and
also Elon Musk is stoking more violence
against Dr fauci and his wife and his
family Dr fauci needing Securities a
doctor he needs security because of the
amount of ire and targeting that has
been done of Dr fauci so the stoking
unrest
um
additionally by the way that tweet for
Milan musk got a million likes on
Twitter so for all of the arguments that
Twitter is a left-wing Cesspool uh the
right wing stuff coming from people like
Elon Musk and others getting a lot of
likes a lot a lot of likes another
aspect to the crazy weekend from Elon
Musk is the following is reported by the
street
Elon Musk threatens Twitter 2.0
employees
um the billionaire social media revamp
efforts are widely covered in the Press
Elon Musk likes to control the narrative
um he has fired a whole bunch of
different people and now he is
threatening leakers people who leak
information with lawsuits that is what
this article is about and I encourage
you to check it out Elon Musk saying
Twitter will immediately seek damages
Twitter will immediately seek damages
Elon Musk is threatening to sue Twitter
employees who leak confidential
information to the Press he's asking
staffers to sign a pledge indicating
they've understood the letter by the way
the how Wild is it that the letter
threatening people about leaking has
leaked
as evidenced by the many detailed leaks
of confidential Twitter information a
few people at our company continue to
act in a manner contrary to the
company's interests and in violation of
their NDA this will be said only once if
you clearly and deliberately violate the
NDA that you signed when you joined you
accept liability to the full extent of
the law and Twitter will immediately
seek damages so it is more and more and
more of this exact same stuff that we
started seeing before Elon Musk even
purchased Twitter of course those on the
right including like on Fox news they
find it all hilarious here's Dagan
McDowell
commenting on the the humor of prosecute
fauci but John Brennan was at it again
over the weekend you know Elon Musk was
going after fauci and uh you know his
regular hilarious way yes prosecute
fauci is just really really funny a
doctor
with Decades of service
who is trying to deal with or has had
been trying to deal with a pandemic a
global pandemic
he needs to be targeted in Elon musk's
humorous way these folks are very
dangerous and at this point it's really
clear that what Elon Musk wants to do
is to promulgate and perpetuate
right-wing disinformation and the
Shilling for that type of uh uh that
type of content on Twitter what his
underlying motivation is I don't really
know and it's speculative is it that he
genuinely has political views that he
believes are best served by fomenting
right-wing disinformation on Twitter
maybe maybe that's what it is is there
some personal financial angle that he
believes would be served by turning
Twitter into some kind of right-wing
disinformation chamber maybe that's the
case uh could it be that he is working
in concert with I don't even know who
and that all together they've decided
let's destroy Twitter from the ends I
don't believe we know yet I believe it's
premature to explain exactly what it is
that is motivating all of this but it is
getting very very bad and I don't
believe it's going to turn around
anytime soon we'll have all of these
clips on our Instagram which you can
find at David Pacman show on Instagram
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
I'm going to play for you today one of
the most outrageous and dangerous
comments I've ever heard from any
elected official ever and certainly that
I have covered on this program radical
republican congresswoman Marjorie Taylor
green said that if she had organized the
Insurrection coup Trump riots on January
6 2021 she would have been armed and
they would have won now what on Earth
does it mean that they would have won
well I think we have some pretty good
ideas of exactly what they mean we're
going to get to that Newsweek reporting
Marjorie Taylor green says Maga would
have won on January 6th if she organized
it what the hell is she talking about
Green was among the high-profile guests
to attend and speak at an event hosted
by the New York young Republican Club
that's a group that's got upper
management written all over it huh that
was in New York City on Sunday evening
Don Jr was there Rudy Giuliani was there
uh conspiracy theorist Jack zabiac was
there and the topic of the capital Riot
came up and here is Marjorie Taylor
green with again let's see if we can ex
understand exactly what she means saying
if she had run the riots they would have
won the riots interesting winning and
losing as the framing
which I thought was hilarious because I
couldn't even find the bathroom and the
capitol
true story
then January 6th happens and next thing
you know I organize the whole thing
along with Steve Bannon here
and I want to tell yourself that if
Steve Bannon and I had organized that we
would have won
[Applause]
wow
to mentioned it would have been armed
whoa
so it would have been a successful
more heavily armed insurrection
if Marge had been running the thing hmm
Second Amendment supporters went in the
capital without guns and they think they
say you organized that I don't think so
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah I mean remember many of them flew
to DC so how exactly are they going to
bring their guns oh well you know you
could check it or it's the fact that
there weren't more guns because remember
there were guns doesn't really tell us
anything about it at all and there's no
both sides to it I mean this this is
this is fascism
want to be important to mention we have
to stop treating the Republican party
like it's a normal political party I'm
not gonna do the Retro retrospective
Rehabilitation of the Republican party
I'm not going to do that
but I will recognize that there was a
time when the disagreements and the
differences with the Republican Party
we're more sane in nature I guess is
what I would say when it was really
about how involved should government be
in helping people to what degree should
the rich be taxed what should the top
tax rates be
there was a time where that was most of
it there was still the crazy stuff there
was I'm not going to pretend that there
was there was there was some of the
crazy stuff it's all crazy stuff now
it's all wannabe authoritarian fascist
dictatorships at this point in time do
whatever we need to do suppress speech
control the media use use prison or the
threat of prison to try to achieve
politicals it's there's no both sides at
this point in time Democrats are trying
to figure out how can we get everybody
health care Republicans are trying to
figure out how can we use guns to get
into office after losing an election
think about that contrast now I wish you
would elaborate on what winning meant
she says we would have won the
Insurrection if I had been in charge
I is she saying we would have
successfully overthrown the government
ending democracy as we know it in the
country by installing a dictatorial
leader who lost his election is that the
win that she's talking about I think it
has to be I don't know what else it
could be
we have to deal with this political
party
not as a normal political party but
rather
as a group of people who want to destroy
the American system of government who
don't care about the Constitution Trump
just said last week you can terminate
the parts of the Constitution that you
want when you believe you have been
wronged as he believes he was wronged in
2020. we have to treat them for what
they are now there's one other I guess
alternative for what it would mean to
have won which is maybe they would have
gotten a few senators and members of the
House killed right it wouldn't have just
been a demand to hang Pence maybe they
would have done it
and then he could have declared martial
law and then he could have suspended the
election process and somehow convinced
people he should be president for an
additional four years I don't know maybe
maybe that's what a win would have
looked like but that's Marjorie Taylor
green she should obviously not be a
member of the House
uh Lauren bober won but barely Madison
cawthorne lost in her very red District
Marjorie Taylor green easily won the
real test now is going to be what
happens to these magas in 2024 we'll be
following it I got emails over the
weekend David you wouldn't dare cover
the investigation into congresswoman
Alexandria ocasio-cortez it doesn't fit
your narrative to talk about the fact
that she's under ethics investigation
come on guys come on you all know I do
not care
about political party or these elected
officials as people and what I mean by
that is it's it's not like I'm saying I
don't I don't care if they get hit by a
car no that's not what I mean is
The Cult of Personality that forms
around so many elected officials I just
don't care about it these are just
people they all they're all they do good
they do bad they have good ideas they
have ideas I don't care for aoc's just
another person that's all and so I would
have no reason to hide from you that AOC
is the subject of a house ethics
investigation that's absolutely the case
that that is going on and it has been
under a democratic house
that's happening the guardian reports
AOC is subject of house ethics
investigation
spokesperson is confident undisclosed
matter quote will be dismissed
the Democratic acting chair Susan Wilde
and acting ranking member Michael guest
released a statement on Wednesday they
say the matter regarding AOC was
transmitted to the committee by the
office of congressional ethics on 23
June the subject was not revealed the
committee said the mere fact of a
referral or an extension and the
mandatory disclosure of such an
extension and the name and subject of
the subject of the matter does not
itself indicate a violation has occurred
what they're saying is
you're innocent until proven guilty
there is an investigation but that
doesn't mean that any violation has
taken place
the house Ethics Committee said it would
announce its course of action after the
new Congress convenes in January
that's what's going on
uh now in September of 2021 the American
accountability Foundation filed an
Ethics complaint against her for quote
accepting an impermissible gift to
attend the Met Gala the event was a 35
000 a ticket event that's where she wore
the tax the rich dress a spokesperson
said she was invited as a guest of the
met and didn't get to keep the dress the
question is whether that may have
violated the ethics rules because even
though she was a guest someone paid for
the ticket and the thirty five thousand
dollar ticket is worth more than the
maximum donation so that there may be
something there now
when some something like this happens
what should the left do for the most
part the left does what it should do if
you think back to Anthony Weiner you
know the the Wright loves to say oh the
left is they have these double standards
they want to go after everyone on the
right but then they want to protect
Hunter Biden or they were defending
Anthony Weiner or they think that an
investigation into AOC is by definition
wrong because she's the darling of the
left
I don't see anyone doing that stuff
think back to the Anthony Weiner
circumstances my view on Anthony Weiner
was skilled politician great speaker
doesn't deserve any particular
protection for the things he is accused
of and he did things wrong and he has to
suffer the consequences with Al Frank
and remember the the bad joke and the
picture with Al Franken that
subsequently left to him led to him
resigning from the Senate
Democrats if they could be criticized
for anything on that were too quick to
demand a resignation too quick when in
the end it seemed like it was more of a
bad joke and misunderstanding than
anything approximating the things that
the right has done and has been accused
of uh uh Hunter Biden listen I don't
know anyone saying Hunter Biden must be
protected there is obviously a political
bias going on when it comes to the
targeting of Hunter Biden there is an
attempt to conflate Hunter Biden with
Joe Biden when Hunter has nothing to do
with the Biden Administration there is
no proof that the big guy that is
referenced in the infamous emails is Joe
by there's just it's obviously grasping
at straws because they have nothing but
I and everybody I'm seeing on the left
says Hunter Biden did something wrong
then investigate him and indict him if
it's a crime and convict him if the
evidence is there who cares nobody he's
defending him and similarly if AOC did
something wrong there should be an
investigation and if it turns out that
indeed she did do something wrong there
should be whatever punishment is
appropriate we just can't have it be
partisan witch hunts that's the concern
and that's why with Hunter Biden when he
clearly has nothing to do with the Biden
Administration the desire to turn the
next Congress into the Congress that
will impeach Biden for things we don't
even really know and investigate Hunter
Biden for the full two years that's when
it gets disgusting and concerning so
that's where we are
let's figure out what AOC did if
anything if she should be fined then
let's find her that's it but let's make
sure that we're doing it equally and
that we're not turning this into a
partisan Witch Hunt we're going to take
a quick break and be right back after
this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show let's do a
couple of quick Trump updates here at
the end of the show much to the pleasure
of many and dismay of others Trump
increasingly having a smaller and
smaller role on this show and in
American politics and I think that
that's a great thing to the extent that
uh he's horrible and dangerous for
American democracy let's start report
from best Levin of the
um Vanity Fair Trump has been
hibernating at home for almost a month
yes Trump has barely left his house
since announcing that he's running for
president in 2024. after a less than
rapturous response to his 2024 campaign
announcement the ex-president has barely
left the grounds of Mar-A-Lago something
is going on here something is going on
um Bess Levin writes about Trump's
preparation to announce the bid for
office and the assumption that this
would start a two-year period in which
he would befetted the world over
everywhere he went people would
spontaneously break into song and dance
thanking their favorite President for
stepping up to rescue the country
it has not really happened that way
Trump has not really been interviewed on
any prominent media since announcing hey
I'm a former president and I'm running
again that's normally would be pretty
big news and as best Levin writes in
reality things didn't entirely pan out
that way almost no one in the Republican
party has come out to support Trump
despite threats to punish Republicans
who don't endorse him Rupert Murdoch's
media Empire has spent considerable time
and effort telling people he's a loser
and a new Yahoo news you gov poll
released Thursday has Florida Governor
Ron DeSantis beating Trump by Five
Points
DeSantis hasn't even announced that he's
running remember instead of 24 7 parades
he was hit with a guilty conviction for
his family business which a jury said
committed 17 different crimes and Ivanka
made clear she wants nothing to do with
Trump's future endeavors so the point
here is Trump's really not leaving his
house he's essentially not leaving the
Washington Post writes Trump's seclusion
within the ornate walls I call them
gaudy you can call them ornate I would
call them gaudy walls Trump's occlusion
within the ornate walls of his club and
a series of controversies from dinner
with anti-semites ya and Nick Fuentes to
a social media post suggesting the
termination of Constitution have left
him isolated within his own party as he
tries to mount a political comeback
Herschel Walker's loss on Tuesday is the
latest blow prompting more Republicans
to join the chorus faulting him for
dragging down the party's performance in
this year's midterms the former
president presents our biggest risk of
losing for 2024 and conservatives are
tired of losing said Bob vanderplatz
head of the family leader a social
conservative group so bottom line
Trump's barely leaving his house and it
seems as though things are not going
particularly well there's one really
funny thing about this now let's let's
talk about the political implications
first we're two years away just under
two years away I guess we're 23 months
away if we want to make a more accurate
countdown from the 2024 election
it's too early to say there's no
momentum and this is going to fail we
don't we just don't know that at this
point in time we need to wait and see if
Trump mounts some momentum this is far
earlier then typically people announce
that they are running but we've already
seen
at least one very good article making
the case that Trump may not even make it
to the first Republican primaries which
I believe I I believe it's Iowa uh I
believe a Taiwan both sides and that if
he doesn't get momentum going at some
point in time he may just drop out
rather than lose now someone like
Michael Cohen all along argued Trump
wouldn't run Trump's running but is he
really running in the sense that if you
announce and then you never leave your
house and then you just slowly and
quietly go away
did you really run maybe not that's
maybe more of a semantic discussion the
really funny thing is that in the run-up
to the 2020 election Trump and Maga and
the Q wing of the party
spent the entire time slamming President
Joe Biden then candidate Joe Biden for
hiding in his basement and not
campaigning now there was a pandemic at
the time you may recall and he still won
and and as I've said before
the really humiliating thing isn't that
Biden was in his basement it's that if
Biden was in his basement Trump lost by
a lot to a guy who was in his basement
but now as the table seemed to turn it's
Trump who is just hanging out out at
home and wishing people getting married
at Mar-A-Lago well and this sort of
thing
uh I don't really know how Trump turns
this thing around and what I mean by
that is he can hold rallies but there's
no rallies for other candidates right
now because there's no other elections
the midterm is over so would a random
Trump rally in January of 2023 when
you're running for something in 2024 is
that going to get attention or is it
going to seem just kind of pathetic I
don't know that's one option number two
who is going to go and kiss the ring at
Mar-A-Lago when it's not clear that
Trump actually maintains the political
cachet that people would in the
Republican Party would feel the need to
do that yes Kerry lake is sucking up to
Trump because she wants to be his VP
yeah Marjorie Taylor green is sucking up
to Trump because she wants to be his VP
but the people and then you've got
people like Mitt Romney who have said
not voting for him no matter what but
it's very clear that the vast majority
of Republicans at this point are taking
a kind of wait and see approach which is
we're not going to get behind him until
we see how much power He commands and at
this point it's not very clear because
he's losing in the polls to people who
haven't even announced namely Ron
DeSantis so we're going to follow it but
this is increasingly a guy who looks
like he's out of options and for now
he's staying at home the one thing he is
doing is he's posting to truth social
truth essential and I want to talk about
that next Donald Trump in a dangerous
confused all capital letters rant once
again and the question continues to be
is this guy actually running for
president or is he just posting to truth
social truth essential
and hoping that people show up and beg
him to save the country even though
Republicans don't seem particularly
interested take a look at this
delusional angry Furious all capital
letters rant that he posted to truth
social at least for now resisting
getting back on Twitter quote and
remember it's all caps folks it's caps
all the way down quote how can the
January 6th unselect committee make
criminal referrals when they haven't
spoken about or studied those that
rigged the 2020 election the troops not
being brought in by Pelosi or now the
election fraud determinatively revealed
by Twitter these are the real criminals
I think there's four lies there
uh first of all the committee can make
criminal referrals because house
committees can make criminal referrals
that's number one number two the 2020
election was not rigged number three the
troops were not not brought in by Pelosi
there is no evidence Nancy Pelosi
blocked nor even had the power to
control the troops and there is no
evidence that Donald Trump requested
tens of thousands of troops as he has
claimed to and number three the Twitter
files did not determinatively reveal any
election fraud they revealed that both
the Trump Administration and the Biden
campaign had the email addresses of
people they could email to request
content be removed and if the content
violated Twitter's terms of service
Twitter sometimes removed it Trump
continuing in all capital letters quote
this was election interference the
disinformation nation was coming from
the FBI and Facebook it was coming from
Adam Schiff and Democrat operatives this
was a very damaging story to Biden
before the election and they were going
to kill it bottom line the election was
rigged and stolen Miranda Devine as
interviewed by Mark Levin amazing so
what's the end game here is Trump's
final foray into public life going to be
announcing that he's running in 2024
staying home as he has for the last
month and posting all capital letters
messages to Troth Central to argue about
how unfairly he was treated telling lie
after lie after lie until he eventually
either for health reasons or for some
other undetermined reason says I'm
actually not going to run I have other
things I want to do because this is not
shaping up to be a very successful
political run that's for damn sure and
at some point if he believed Joe Biden
had to leave his house in order to win
which by the way apparently he didn't uh
at some point Trump's going to have to
do something other than just posting all
capital letters messages on Truth
Central now I get it it's early we're 23
months away from the 2024 election but
is this going to be it is this going to
be the last gasp and whimper of Trump's
failed political career I don't know we
will wait and see together we have a
voicemail number that number is 2192
David P I want to continue reminding you
there are people pretending to be me
trying to scam you on YouTube Here's a
new scam involving ps5s PlayStation
fives I think these are I think the five
is the newest one is it I don't know
I've never owned a PlayStation listen to
this
yes my name is Brenda and
um I listen to your show a lot
and somebody contacted me saying through
you right that I won
um PlayStation 5 blah blah blah blah
blah no and my ID has been ripped off a
lot so I did not give him my address
good and I just want to know if it's
real no it is not real okay so I've told
you many times before
I don't want you to text me okay if you
if you comment on you on YouTube and
then it looks like I'm saying hey cool
please text me it's not me all right I
don't want to chat with you on WhatsApp
if you're getting responses on YouTube
saying David uh saying uh uh sir or
ma'am I'm David please chat with me on
Whatsapp it's not me and I am not giving
away any PlayStation fives I'm not
giving away game boys Commodore 64s
Xboxes Xbox 360s Super Nintendo Nintendo
Genesis I'm not giving away Jaguar
Jaguar however okay I'm not I have no
Ataris or video game consoles to give
away
these are scams one thing that is
upsetting me
the people that are being targeted we
we've been investigating this the people
being targeted in my YouTube comments
oftentimes they will say in their
comments their age and it's usually
above 65. so there are now five people
who were targeted by these scammers on
YouTube who in their comments said David
I'm 68 and I watch you every day boom
thank you so much for your comment I'd
like you to text me next thing you know
they're getting scammed so few things
here maybe don't post your age in the
comments I don't need to know your age
when you leave a comment I'm not texting
just don't respond folks report them
we're reporting them as quickly as we
can but these are scams I'm not looking
to give away anything all right please
please please on today's bonus show oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
find themselves is bad producer Pat was
sent my pillow pillows
and he is going to review them there's a
whole backstory to how he ended up with
the pillows instead of me okay we're
gonna get to that number two
one vote made a difference in a
Massachusetts house election after a
recount one vote had been miscounted
and it changed the winner
Amazon is being accused of stealing tips
from delivery drivers
and the baby whose parents didn't want
the baby to get quote vaccinated blood
if necessary during a life-saving heart
surgery has had the life-saving heart
surgery we will tell you what happened
what went down it's an incredible story
but the good news is the baby had the
procedure all of those stories and more
on today's bonus show it's really easy
to get access to the bonus show just
sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code please no more Trump and you have
to say it with that tone when you type
it in please no more Trump that's the
code you save you become a member it's
an amazing thing and I will see you on
the bonus show in mere moments otherwise
we'll be back tomorrow with another new
episode
[Music]
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors give directly is
the non-profit that lets you send cash
directly to the world's poorest
household which is more cost effective
than so many other types of giving it's
how you know you're maximizing your
donations help us reach our goal of
fifteen thousand dollars by the end of
the year go to give
directly.org Pacman